such analysis to understand and
characterize these variants can be
performed at many different levels to
investigate the functions of variety of
different genes in multiple different
research areas right these research
areas can include
drug metabolism by studying the enzyme
function that
by studying the enzyme function that is
key in the
catalysis and the key in the
functionality of specific metabolite and
this can also end up trying to
characterize we can also end up trying
to characterize uh mutations in specific
genes that can cause tumor in that case
um
genes that are linked with tumor
progression and tumor genesis and we
already spoke about sickle cell anemia
this in case this um
in this example is uh
um
is spoiled
by the effects of germline mutations
that are inherited
from uh from our parents so furthermore
one can also use uh
use genomics to explore pathogens and to
understand uh important properties of
their pathogens as a result of their or
as a function of their genomic variance
to study virulence to study disease
transmission and to study drug
resistance etc etc many of these
examples will become clear as we review
several projects
project and exemplar
projects as we go along in the sessions
as we go along the program
and some of this we can also discuss in
uh in the upcoming
slides
in today's session so if you have any
questions please
let us know in the chat box we will
discuss that before going to specific
examples
that will help us understanding the
genomic variance analysis
okay if there are no other questions
let's proceed
so
so until now we have tried to understand
the concepts and the types of variants
and mutations and how to
for example characterize them so let's
understand why and how these mutations
uh
yes actually this will be available
so let's understand
how
these mutations
and variants play very important role in
the progression of development of cancer
or
better can we say
how can the how can the mutations will
actually help in
tumor formation so we know we already
know that there are various important
genes that play
key roles in cell cycle and regulation
of cell growth and etc so any
disturbances in these genes will
actually result in dysregulation of cell
growth and
eventually enhancing the development of
tumor so let's if if we focus on those
genes and
focus on variants and variations on
those genes which could result in tumor
development we can actually discuss
a couple of examples for example they
are
these genes are actually generally
termed as tumor suppressor genes because
usually these genes regulate the cell
growth and if they
um
for example if they encounter any
defects in the cell growth they end up
they end up inducing apoptosis and hence
saving
saving the eventual progression or
eventual
progression of the tumor and
development of tumor and progression of
the tumor in these samples but
if the genes
if these tumor suppressor genes get
mutated and for example get inactivated
it will for
or the mutated version may end up
altering the normal function of these
genes then the regulation
will be affected and eventually that
could result in uncontrolled growth of
these cells
so some of the examples of tumor
suppressor genes that you can easily
relate and you can actually
find everywhere in the bio biomedical
research area is a tp53 that we all all
know about and p10 or some of them
so
these genes that are responsible for
cell growth and
potential mutation that is caused in
these genes may result in promoting
for example promoting
tumor are termed as oncogenes and
there are sorry
there are also some of the genes that
are responsible for cell growth and if
any mutation
um in these genes that are responsible
for cell growth can be
uh
promoting
or
accelerating or actually
amplifying their normal function but
that was what i was looking for
amplifying the normal function and these
genes at their normal level that promote
cell growth but at that amplified level
can promote abnormal growth are termed
as oncogenes and any mutation that
results in uncontrolled cell growth will
again result in tumor genesis and we can
actually um
find some of the examples of these
encode genes that are
hair 2 which is epidermal growth factor
receptor human epidermal growth factor
receptor her2 that is one of the
oncogene and some mutations in these
genes will actually result in
these receptor binding to a lot of
growth factors and promoting
abnormal
growth of the cell and that is also
another oncogene which is epidermal
growth factor themselves right egfr
epidermal growth factor receptor
themselves and this again will bind to
many growth factor molecules and promote
tumor
tumor progression and human tumor
genesis in general and there are also
other forms of genes and other genes
which which will
which are
involved in dna repair mechanisms for
example and any mutations in these dna
repair g mechanism
involving genes may also end up
changing the
characteristics of the cells to a
malignant level so some of these
mutations can be acquired uh which is
the most common case of
the cancer they can be acquired due to
stress they can be acquired due to many
many times copying the
dna code to several
generations and they can also be
acquired due to
random chances right and some of these
mutations can also be
can also be a result of hereditary
hereditary
cause or these are all termed as
germline mutations which are less common
and the genes that are famous for
germline mutations are the bracha genes
so if um
if the bracha if specific mutations in
the brca1 and brca2 genes get propagated
from the parents to daughters or from
the parents to
cells
from the parents to progeny then that
will result in
most likely or
result in a higher risk of developing
breast cancer and ovarian cancers etc so
some of the mutations that are acquired
for example
may be concentrated in several different
portions of the gene and
these are all somatic mutations or
acquired mutations and those
mutations which are known to cause
humor tumeric genesis or tumor
progression or cause cancer are termed
as driver mutations and those mutations
which are known to be associated with
the
presence of cancer but their
their clear relationship with the cancer
development if that is not known then
those mutations are called
passenger mutations and when one
discusses
or when one
focus on on one specific gene for
example tp53 gene which is very well
known um
for uh
for its yeah for the for the protein
that is tb2
in tb 53 and this protein as we already
discussed acts as a tumor suppressor and
regulates the cell division by keeping
the grow growth and cell division under
control under control so this the
mutations that are present in tp53 are
are of numerous uh uh
type and also known as variety and you
can actually uh check right if i'm if i
did not butcher your name um you can go
to uh repositories like cosmic and
mainly cosmic to study
potentially pathogenic
somatic mutations related to one
specific gene so if you
if you type tp53 gene in cosmic then it
will end up listing all the known
variants and mutation that is known to
cause
that is known to be associated with the
tumor development themselves so there
are also other forms of annotation in
the cosmic database which will
annotate the mutations to be potentially
driver or potentially passenger or
unknown
causes etcetera
so this
tp53 gene themselves it is implicated in
many cancers not only in specific type
of cancer many cancers and it helps
as we already discussed it induces
hypotosis and when it when the protein
actually this
when the protein actually detects some
abnormality in the
in the genes and
and
several of the mutations that is present
in the in the specific regions that bind
and
recognize
dna code can lead to
promote need to be promoting
chemogenesis by not controlling the
replication of the cells with damaged
dna so this protein will bind to dna and
will
identify incorrectly
uh translated
[Music]
replicated g a replicated basis and
when you observe several mutations in
the binding site of these genes that
will actually
that are actually usually associated
with tumor promoting
driver genes and there are also other
variations or other variants and other
mutations that are generally observed in
the structure of the tp53 genes
protein which may not be directly
related to their functionality but
one has to say or one has to
keep an open mind that we have not
completely understood the effect of
those mutations until now even though we
have uh understood many different
mutations on there involvement in tumor
uh
genesis for tp53 gene specific
so this the the relationship between
disease causing mutation is not limited
to cancer in fact
this is
this relationship and prevention has
been uh has developed a lot uh has been
for example
worked upon in lot of other diseases
compared to cancer like one of the very
well known story is about cystic
fibrosis right cystic fibrosis is is
is
as we know is can be
understood as it causes chronic lung
infections by
by the changes in the mucous secretion
so it is usually or generally caused by
mutations in one single gene that is a
cftr cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulated gene
so
this mutation can actually result in
either no cftr protein being produced or
some of the proteins that are produced
may be
may
may be ill-formed or malformed and they
cannot perform their key functionality
in the cell and there are depending upon
what happens or depending upon the
variety of different variants there are
five class of these cftr mutations and
they can occur in different
different
stages from the protein synthesis to
producing insufficient protein the most
common disease causing mutation in all
these five different classes of cftr is
this uh
is this protein processing or maturation
processing protein where this one
specific amino acid phenylalanine is
actually deleted and this actually
occurs in more than 80 percentage of the
patients and
and that causes uh
in incorrect uh
regulation of the
of the mucous formation and hence it
results in chronic lung disease
there are also other uh mutations like
uh like the one that is in uh like the
one that is in the in the
in the gating that involves the gating
mechanism like glycine to aspartate and
which causes complete loss of
the
protein in the plasma membrane by um
by causing by by resulting in the gate
being too narrow so
generally the life expectancy of these
cystic fibrosis patients can be
improved or can be linked when we
diagnose these mutations early and
when some of the symptomatic treatment
therapeutic regimens are produced but
these are actually results of um
hereditary mutations
right
they are germline mutations and um
one can observe the presence of these
mutations
when we look for these specific
mutations from the development stage of
the progeny stem cells right so
depending upon where uh this mutation
occurs as we see that
there are several advancements in
[Music]
in understanding these cftr modular in
understanding the cftr mutations has
been made and specific
gene modulators for these specific
mutations are also developed and these
modulated drugs have the ability to
for example
restore partially or fully the
functional expression of these specific
cf-causing mutations and they also have
been classified into addressing these
specific mutation um separately or
accordingly so this
highlights the importance of studying
genomic variants
no i mean
yeah that's a great question kumal why
only 39 mutations of cftr is considered
for modulated treatment why not the
other
1700 mutations so we can only act upon
those mutations which
for which we can successfully generate
or develop modulation
there may be
several other mutations and
many of these mutations may remain
uncharacterized or may not be reachable
themselves the modulators are also
therapeutic drugs that that has limited
reachability or that has limited uh
functionality one has to identify or one
has to
use only certain targets of these
certain target mutations of these cftr
no so that is why um
we
people are still working on these
modulated productions and cftr is very
actively
developing research area understanding
cft organizations is very actively
developing the such area and one has to
keep saying that these modulators will
only partially
may only partially restore the
functionality of the cftr and um several
more research has to be
successfully developed and successfully
performed to
generally increase the quality of life
of these patients
until now we have only succeeded in
extending the life expectancy of these
patients and eventually when we end up
in
end up in improving the quality of the
life then people can actually consider
this as a success story but nonetheless
understanding the
mutation at several different molecular
level will actually help us
generate specific intervention for those
specific variants of mutation and can
actually help the um
help treat patients suffering from these
deadly diseases in this condition right
so
ah
mutations classified at uh for example
categorized as at single nucleotide
positions uh are not the only cause of
disease uh not only this is causing
mutation for example in the case of um
uh i'm not a professor yet common thank
you so um in the case of huntington's
disease which is a rare inheritance
inherited disease we already know they
cause um
um for example uh progressive breakdown
of the nerve cells in the brain and this
has a wide impact in person's functional
abilities and it usually results in
movement disorders usually result in
cognitive disorders and and may end up
resulting in psychiatric disorders in
for example
we know that huntington's disease is an
inherited condition where uh instead of
point mutations that we have been
discussing so far a specific gene on the
chromosome 4 has an abnormal number of
cag codons this is an example of
duplication mutation that we discussed
or that we just touched upon earlier so
where the cag codon is actually
multiple times reproduce or multiple
times
are duplicated in the htt or huntington
g so this gene encodes a very large
huntingtin protein and these additional
repeats actually change the change the
structure of the protein completely and
this is the result of
progressive movement disorder or
dementia behavior abnormalities etc etc
for example
the huntington diseases
typically emerge in
around midlife 45 55 or even later at
that point but there are certain cases
and there are specific cases where
juvenile onset has been observed and
when when we can if we can diagnose the
presence of these
characteristics motor signs
based on the presence of these
characteristic motor signs then we can
look for these mutations in those
juvenile concept cases that is what has
been done
by the huntington consortium
in 2015 which published a study of over
1000 individuals with early and late
onset of this disease and by
by understanding the whole genome
sequencing and understanding the
targeted sequencing of specific
chromosome 4
sequencing researchers discovered
very important regulatory mechanisms
that are differentiated between the
groups
for which we observe early disease or
early onset and for another which we
observe late onset and that
actually
is associated with the
chromosome 15 where we have abnormal
copy number variations of a specific
gene and and that results in the slower
development of the
of this specific uh
this is progression and etcetera of
different mechanism of this is
progression and uh
this
chromosome 15
for example
this specific uh
gene in the chromosome 15 that got
have abnormal number of copy number
variation here
can actually help us identify mechanisms
of this disease progression and help us
develop therapeutic
therapeutic intervention so now what i
was actually trying to say is the
chromosome four is what is associated
with the development of the huntington
disease but when when they perform uh
this targeted sequencing effort in these
100 1000 individuals with early onset
and late onset their differential
variant analysis resulted in identifying
specific regions of chromosome 15 that
had higher number of copy number variant
or higher number of copy number
operation and for them right those which
pro which
for those who contain this higher number
of copy number operated chromosome 15
they are associated with the slower
development of this huntington disease
and by understanding this variant in
particular
one can identify mechanisms of these
disease progression and relate that to
the therapeutic intervention um by
naturally understanding the disease
regulation and etcetera etcetera and
that is what this study actually helped
us
understand in in specific so where uh
without any intervention and natural
variation that occurred for specific
group of people
acted as a potential regulatory
mechanism for a deadly disease we can
exploit to
treat these specific early onset of
huntington's disease
so
proceeding further we can actually
turn our focus into pathogen
genomics data analysis in this case we
already know tuberculosis is so
difficult to
treat because
they usually attack the lungs and they
can spread to other parts of the body
like brain spine etc and this is caused
by mycobacterium tuberculosis why is
this so important in the 20th century
alone tuberculosis was the leading cause
of the united states and today
most cases are usually cured with very
difficult to follow and very complicated
antibiotics regime right but
in the last three years or four years
researchers have actually
discovered that this bacteria has become
more and more resistant to
not one but several different types of
antibiotics so it turns out that this
resistance can be associated with a
specific set of mutations in specific
genes or their promoters so
understanding which gene and which
antibiotic that that gene
mutation i mean resistant to it which
antibiotic that that gene is associated
to
are very important in understanding the
development of resistance in general so
there are also large for example part of
developing new drugs to
address this surge of multi-drug
resistant tuberculosis infections
themselves and in addition to this
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis there
is an existence of extensively
drug-resistant tuberculosis which is
resistant to all different types of
antibiotics or most of the different
types of antibiotics that is it has been
tested
so there are multiple studies that
focuses on understanding
the population level or population
personal
[Music]
a distribution of these multiple drug
resistant and extensively drug resistant
tuberculosis from single infected
single infected isolated area and there
are also studies for example in uh as
you will know in in some of the example
projects that we have um study 20 year
22 years old study performed in single
patient to understand the development of
drug resistant to variety of different
drugs
that are
that that used to treat that specific
patient
so we have more examples like examples
in ebola virus where we know that the
viral protein vp24 is is a nucleocapsid
protein that is associated with uh
inhibiting interfere
gene expression and interferon mediated
antiviral response so this actually
prevents the nuclear importer
import of the signal transducer and the
activator of the
stat1 and hence the interferon mediated
antiviral response is heavily
depleted in the ebola virus affected
infected patients but several studies on
um specific um
strain of ebola virus that that exists
with
reduced
transmissibility and reduced
disease
pathogenicity or virulence actually
identifies specific mutations at
residues 142 146
that are able to for example
reduce the
activity of the vp 24 by 90 percentage
right so this uh these mutations that
are naturally occurring were the result
or whether
one of the starting point that ended up
helping us develop vaccines for these
ebola virus
in this specific epidemic at 2014 2016.
so there are other examples as well for
example
this considers or this actually
discusses the use of
understanding the
rhizophy rhizosphere which is defined as
the soil zone
around the plant roots right and this
soil
as we know is is rich in nutrients and
in this region there is an intense
interaction that takes place between the
plant root tips and plant roots and the
microbes that are present in the soil
microbes that are present in the plant
roots right these microbes inhibiting or
inhabiting area are generally termed as
rhizobacteria and they can actually
regulate
all the known bio geochemical cycles of
this specific space and they can
regulate degradation of organic
chemicals and they can actually preserve
the um
components of the soil chemistry
and understanding the mutability or
mutation of uh
of the for example um
mutability
of
mutability in all the positions
of this rhizobacteria genome
can actually help us understand the
variety on variation that is present in
several different rhizobacterial genome
in in specific there are and there are
some couple of publications that are
involved in isolating specific
isobacteria genome and
association studies glass-like studies
in understanding the
heterozygosity of this specific riso
bacteria which we know are very
beneficial to uh
maintaining the healthy ingredients of
the soil
biosphere
people actually characterized
mutations that are beneficial to
maintaining these
these interactions that are attaining at
a at a healthy rate and some of the
mutations that are known to cause a
depletion in their functionality of the
ratio bacterial rhizobacterium
genome in general so that is also
possible so this is not
only limited to
for example uh um
understanding the bacterial genome that
that inhibits are that that are
inhibited of the habit uh inhibited of
the soil lysosphere one can also use uh
uh
general genomics data analysis in uh
in uh promoting crop yield and in
promoting
generating the genetics of agriculture
which precedes the use of genomics in
agriculture by several decades so the
efforts in those areas are also heavily
heavily advancing because generally when
you see the amount of data that is
available for us to compare our samples
with are focused more on human genome
and this is causing human genes and less
on
general crop yields and crop production
and agriculture in in
in general so in those
in those aspects people focus on uh not
comparing the genome with the reference
genome if the reference genome is not
present then they
work out or then they
perform
glass like studies in trying to sample
variety of different
genomes and understand the variation
that is present at different levels
inside the
plant sequences etc so this is not
limited to only plants this is uh this
can exist at different levels um
also in in metagenomics levels also you
can
you will get a
deep and detailed understanding of
of these applications when you go
through some of the associated resources
that are listed in introduction to
bioinformatics and sometimes bites and
molecules in the
resources so
with that i will conclude today's
lecture and in the next following
sessions
we will focus more about uh
more about the important part of these
studies that are related to our ability
to compare the dna code from given
individual to a reference right this
comparison is actually made possible
through the computational advances that
will take millions of these short treats
and align themselves to the reference to
extract meaningful insights as we have
been discussing so far so the next
session is to understand the basic
concepts of sequence analysis through
performing the sequence analysis in in
an environment like r so you will start
with uh understanding what is a dna
sequence string and why we need to
compare it
with the reference sequence and what do
we gain by comparing it with the
reference sequence and what are the what
are the variants that we can actually
characterize you can perform this
alignment yourself and what are the
different types of alignment that one
can focus on and how to do
a test alignment in our case and how to
do
similar analysis by uploading files in
uh in our talbot bioinfo platform and
visualize the output
in jbrowser or igb etcetera etcetera
that will be our
discussion for the next session